this video is brought to you by petal
[Music]
what up guys greg here by now we've all
seen the array of strange things men are
told to do
to enhance our bodies eat more meat do
no tropics
biohack by injecting plasma into your
absolutely not and if you've ended up on
a certain side of youtube you might have
seen things like this
did you know that the average adult has
5 to 20 pounds of toxic
poop in their body or this group of rats
actually outperformed the control group
on many different biomarkers and these
biomarkers included
preventing age-related ball shrinkage
significantly increased ball size when
compared to the control group
and this isn't some cottage industry
wellness but for dudes
has become an increasingly large segment
of the multi-trillion dollar wellness
market but what exactly
are they trying to get us to buy and
since when did an industry dominated by
the gwyneth paltrows and kardashians of
the world
subtly become obsessed with your
pectoral definition
and we're gonna freaking goop it up in
here
whether it's about toxic poop or
increasing your genital size
these days the wellness industry has a
whole host of supplements and diet plans
to revolutionize
our lives and make us better men and the
figureheads of this movement are people
like
mma enthusiast turned podcasters what's
your morning routine like or do you have
a morning routine that you like or do
you just kind of fasted cardio
that's what i like to do or fasted yoga
or
super bowl winners like tom brady when
you're pushing the limits to get better
a lot of the times you know the limits
push back his wellness brand tb12
sells everything from powdered gatorade
to fancy jump ropes
often their sales pitches hinge on the
idea of
overcoming physical adversities like
injury or poor health
on top of the lack of fda approval for
most of these products
some of them are just plain weird sure
they might not be selling jade eggs to
uh
put inside yourself but are some of the
supplements and schemes pushed by the
male wellness industry
just goop but for men let's find out in
this wise crack edition
on male wellness what went wrong
and before we get into it i want to give
a special thanks to this video
sponsor pedal the pedal 2 card is
designed to help you build credit
many credit card companies base your
credit limit or credit worthiness
or your credit score but if you haven't
established a credit score yet
it can be almost impossible to get
approved if you don't have a credit
score
pedal uses your banking history to
create a cash score
which is essentially just a measure of
your income spending
and savings the pedal 2 card is
partnered with web bank
member fdic which issues the card the
pedal 2 card has no annual fees and
currently has variable
aprs ranging from 12.99
to 26.99 the pedal 2's credit limit
starts at 500
and can range up to 10 000 which can
help keep your credit utilization low
on top of that you'll immediately get
one percent cash back
and after you make 12 on time monthly
payments you'll get 1.5 percent cash
back
so check out the pedal 2 card today go
to pedalcard.com
wisecrack to find out more that's pebble
with the t
p e t a l card.com wisecrack
now back to the show so what is the male
wellness industry
actually selling for the most part the
idea of peak fitness
tom brady's tb12 brand sells dietary
supplements
so that average non-super bowl winning
men
can finally have muscle durability but
this fitness isn't always about
muscularity
supplements have also been said to
improve your immune system
and reduce inflammation which is
supposedly a big deal
what was interesting was the pains back
pain
knee pain what is that it's inflammation
on top of this we can get a whole host
of chemicals called nootropics
specifically designed to help our brains
function with hyper masculine names like
alpha brain but the wellness industry
doesn't just seek to profit off the idea
of being better
it also seeks to fix problems which men
could find
embarrassing like erectile dysfunction
anxiety
or hair loss hey i did this on purpose
they'll tell you that hormonal
imbalances are the reason for your
failing sex life then show you how to
solve it by buying a hundred dollar
blend of basic supplements
the industry can fluctuate between
trying to sell you beta blockers which
are genuinely used to treat anxiety when
trying to convince you to let people
inject platelets
i.e the component of your blood that
helps with clotting
into your penis to help with sexual
performance
and treat erectile dysfunction with
limited science to back it up
we hear success stories from people who
use the carnivore diet to lose weight
and improve their mental health or who
went viral for injecting stem cells
into their dicks or inventing a coffee
that helps your brain work real good and
stuff
and we think there's something goopy
about the method of bro
pseudoscience and the self-empowering
ideology
they use to sell it to us but how do
they get millions of men to buy in on
this stuff
and why did i spend the summer of 2019
drinking a p
based protein powder that tastes like
vintage chalk
by appropriating the exact same
strategies of some very unbroken brands
companies like goop and the people
telling you to detoxify your colon to
expel your toxic dumps
both employ the two main tactics
pseudoscience
and ideology specifically the ideology
that by doing these things we are
becoming our better selves
some wellness brands particularly when
they're selling you dietary supplements
use
scientific sounding language to help
lure people into buying their products
it can be hard to wade through the
jargon so let's dive into what's really
going on
pseudoscience and what we're calling
braille science is a collection of
beliefs or practices
mistakenly regarded as being based on
scientific evidence
and has been going on at least since the
first slick grifter
started selling fake snake oil knocking
off an actual chinese remedy and selling
products with unproven effectiveness is
still common within the wellness
industry especially at places like goop
the essence of group science is used in
a sprinkling of genuine research
and buzzwords combined with people's
personal testimonials to sell us the
idea that buying a particular product
or doing a particular activity will have
definite health benefits for all of us
wellness schemes rely on individual
experts or mere
handfuls of studies to back up things
like paltrow injecting a serum made of
her own blood into her face to make her
skin
healthier and i do like that it's uh
it's my own material it's not a toxin
goop does things like promoting the idea
that regular tampons are somehow toxic
and the only way to mitigate the
dangerous chemicals is to buy goops
own organic bread or the idea that doing
yoga in the snow might actually help you
beat cancer now
some of this isn't total nonsense
meditation and breathing techniques have
long been known to help with physical
and mental illnesses but it becomes
pseudoscience as the claims about its
effectiveness
become more outrageous and less
scientifically proven
to influence their inflammation which is
disease
using three pillars breathing techniques
gradual gold exposure and
mindset just as companies like goop and
um make
toxins the bad guy doodle science makes
inflammation the enemy to health and
wellness
without any real justification or
reasoning toxins and inflammations
are after all very scary words like
knife pillow which is a pillow for your
knives obviously
right we all know that the male wellness
industry constantly vilifies
inflammation whether they're pushing
supplements or diets as if it is not
simply a natural immune response while
some people do struggle with autoimmune
diseases and other issues to do with
inflammation
there are surprisingly few studies on
the actual benefits
of so-called anti-inflammatory diets
maybe the root for many people of a lot
of
causes of pain and discomfort is just
inflammation heavy diet you get all that
out of your system and your body doesn't
experience inflammation from your food
joe rogan and jordan peterson's
carnivore diet has certainly helped them
to lose weight but there aren't many
studies on the benefits of eating little
but grass-fed elk
and eggs twice a day in fact the diet
can leave you lacking in important
nutrients and vitamins due to the no
fruits and vegetables things so doctors
recommend either not doing the diet or
taking plenty of supplements to balance
out all that elk and eggs
on the whole the carnivore diet is
pretty poorly researched
and the idea that it can cure depression
has even less
scientific backing the combination of
anecdotal evidence and genuinely
bad science can make some of the
recommendations made by the likes of joe
rogan
about as effective as recommending fight
milk
the first alcoholic dairy based protein
drink four bodyguards
by bodyguard as far as anecdotal
evidence goes podcasters and
quarterbacks aren't the only ones used
in their personal stories to promote
particular diets or products
um zoo the toxic poop supplement company
was founded by christopher walker who
uses a story of
naturally curing his brain tumor to
challenge the modern pharmaceutical
industry by selling supplements which
reduce the toxicity of your poop and
allegedly give you bigger
testicles wait why does he want bigger
balls
is that a thing is that is that a good
thing sometimes this pseudoscience is
actually backed up by
medical professionals like the numerous
doctors featured in the goop lab
and it might be backed up with some sort
of science these rats have extremely
similar reproductive systems
as human men but as any decent scientist
would tell you
rats aren't humans and research done on
animals isn't always conclusive
i mean unless we're talking about
charlie cheese huh
all right other times it's even backed
up by people pretending to be medical
professionals
tom brady's tb12 business partner alex
guerrero
faked being a doctor and claimed his
snake oil like supplements could cure
cancer
brady also famously uses ambiguous
sciency words
with no direct medical meaning like
muscle pliability to sellers exercise
plans and supplements some of the
science behind these supplements come
from
genuine research or information on
traditional medicine
herbs like ashwagandha are used in
supplements by both goop and
infowars and have been sold to help with
things like stress
or as the alpha bros and infowars
describe it general weakness
and there are some actual studies into
it being effective for stress reduction
where goop cells why am i so effin tired
a variety of vitamins including the herb
bacopa
infowar sold the exact same herb in the
form of a capsule named
brain force and again some studies have
shown benefits but at the same time
both companies sold other products like
colloidal silver
a scientifically unresearched liquid
containing silver that the fda has sued
companies from making false claims
about regarding its efficacy and safety
a lot of supplements from nootropics to
alzheimer's cures are sold before
they've been proven to work or been
safety checked
all in the name of dudes once and for
all becoming their true warrior selves
and this is where ideology comes in
because
pseudoscience aside products sold by
wellness companies are about more than
just approval
from sketchy doctors they hinge on the
idea that without a sixty dollar tub of
ashwagandha we're wasting our lives as
sad sack versions of ourselves and this
ideology of self-improvement
isn't just used by goop to me it's all
like laddering up to one thing which is
optimization of self it's also used in
the male
wellness sphere by companies like alpha
brain pedaling
on it who capitalize on the idea that
without nootropics to enhance your brain
you can't properly do anything i i
really felt like i didn't want to do
anything without it
like i felt like if i was gonna do
stand-up if i was gonna do the ufc
like i wanted to be fully charged though
research is still emerging about things
like alpha brain with studies showing
varied effectiveness it is undoubtedly
an
element of the wellness industry which
profits from its high profile
endorsements
and this will make you smarter and
better marketing strategy
tb12 even applied this strategy to their
immunity plan with the first step being
have a positive mindset at tb12 we
pulled together a list of what we feel
are 12 very important things that you
can do
on a daily basis to help support a
healthy immune system
number one would be to keep a positive
tb12 mindset
expect the best and don't fear the worst
and this comes right back to the idea of
the anecdotal evidence these people
found success through supplements and
dieting
so why can't you this is where the diet
industry and wellness industry overlap
they both make you feel bad about
yourself so that you'll buy
but with male wellness the dieting
element has a twist
not only are we encouraged to lose
weight but we're also encouraged to
replace it with
muscle through intense exercise and of
course
nutritional supplements they'd be like
whoa look at that monster coming towards
us you know barreling towards us
mac you're not that guy anymore
don't you think i know that and i'm
starting to think that i'll never become
that monster again but where
did this concept of muscular masculinity
as a form of self-improvement come from
early pioneers of dieting restricted
themselves to mere ounces of food in the
hopes it would help them live longer
or look thinner at the turn of the 20th
century bad diets like fletcherism the
technique of chewing your food
until it becomes completely liquefied in
order to lose weight were picked up by
figures like franz kafka
in the states it wasn't until the 1930s
that the idea of becoming muscular was
popularized by charles atlas who went
from a self-described scrawny weakling
to a
so-called world's most perfectly
developed man
and naturally thanks to our friend
capitalism he began to make money
selling his bodybuilding secrets through
a company which still exists today
his website claims he is the ideal male
specimen for 20th century man
but in recent years the diet industry
has been somewhat supplanted by the
wellness
industry which promotes the same ideas
while promising broader results like
improved mental health for example
if you eat only red meat you'll lose
weight and be less depressed
if you take supplements you'll stop
losing hair and be less anxious about it
companies use language of empowerment to
sell products for example
the better version of you would take
supplements use face creams
and take vitamin gummies every day the
wellness industry commodifies common
health problems
faced by vast numbers of men it does so
by making them believe that the best way
to address these problems
isn't through a medical professional but
by taking their future into their own
hands
and buying a 40 bottle of pills or a one
pound bag of protein powder which you
know
is a compelling pitch in the country
where access to medical care
is less than great holistic language
about healing and reducing stress
are common slogans and selling points
with supplements in both the men's
and women's wellness industries it turns
out that no matter the gender
corporations will always capitalize on
your fears of getting old
being unhealthy and just not being good
enough and this doesn't come without
consequences
the combination of ideology and
pseudoscience can sometimes
actually be detrimental to your mental
and physical health
diets recommended within the wellness
sphere can be particularly damaging and
most people recommending these diets are
aware of these issues
i took a bunch of different vitamins and
nutrients and supplements
on top of this carnivore diet but the
way they're sold as some kind of miracle
cure based on anecdotal evidence
fronted by charismatic and fit men like
tom brady can leave people at a danger
of developing eating disorders
this is a risk with all restrictive or
calorie controlled diets but is an
overlooked issue especially as eating
disorders are already under diagnosed in
men
doctors have recognized disorders like
orthorexia rising in recent years
due to the growing obsessions with clean
eating
and treating your body right orthorexia
happens when these obsessions reach an
unhealthy level like when someone limits
their diet to only healthy or clean
foods
in serious cases this limitation can
become so obsessive that the person ties
their worth to the idea of healthiness
leading to malnutrition weight loss and
mental health issues like depression and
anxiety
we're seeing a similar rise of disorders
like protorexia an obsession with
protein-based diets often involving
supplements and shakes
and muscle dysmorphia a type of body
dysmorphia related to the perception
that someone's
muscles are not big enough obviously
working out is great but trying to turn
yourself into an
atlas like god can make it an unhealthy
obsession
okay everybody are you ready
bam in fact a lot of things encouraged
by the wellness industry
eating healthy protein exercise
mindfulness have genuine benefits
studies have shown that protein
supplementation and resistance exercise
training can enhance
changes in muscle size and strength and
things like tom brady's exercise regime
isn't in itself bad for you what appears
to be pseudoscience can sometimes be
genuinely promising
while blood platelets might not cure
your sad penis
shockwave therapy might actually help
treat erectile dysfunction which sounds
straight out of a sci-fi movie
but if it works who are we to judge man
and there's nothing fundamentally wrong
with buying coffee that you think will
enhance your brain
or starting a new skincare regime so you
never ever age
but it's the culture around the idea of
wellness that does the damage
the on fda approved supplements and the
concept of needing to biohack
supplement and transform yourself to
finally be happy
at the end of the day bro scientists and
big names in the male wellness industry
capitalize on our fears of getting old
going bald and disappointing our sexual
partners
in the same ways the diet industry has
for decades
but because of the popular figureheads
anecdotal evidence
and carefully selected experts that
market to us
we can be distracted from the goopiness
of it all
but what do you guys think does the
wellness industry actually help men
by giving them expensive ways to feel
better about themselves
or is it just a penis scented candle
away
from being goop for dudes let us know
what you think in the comments
as always thanks to our awesome patrons
for all your support
hit that subscribe button like you're
doing tv 12 bodyweight exercises
and don't forget to ring that bell as
always
thanks for watching peace
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you